okay we're gonna talk about pins anybody
know what a pin is yeah okay it's where
you can't move one of your pieces what
were you gonna say okay perfect
all right anybody see a way to make an
effective pin in this position yeah use
chess notation that's the best way right
so tell me in chess language how you win
in this position is black yeah exactly
exactly so in this position white would
have nothing better than to either
sacrifice his queen for the rook or move
his king off so we can absolutely can't
move the Queen away right because then
it would be check so this is a good use
of a pin yes it's true but if we eat the
rook then what happens then the King
captures and what is this well it's not
a stalemate but it what's the difference
between a stalemate and a draw does
anybody know this is kind of similar to
the whole rectangle and square thing
yes exactly
okay stalemate is a position where you
can't move anywhere but you're not in
check and it is a draw but it's that the
only way to make a draw in chess or
where are there other ways there are
other ways right so a stalemate is a
type of draw not every draw as a
stalemate
anybody knows some other ways that you
can draw besides stalemate yes mm-hmm
right like this position in this
position it's just king verse King it's
not a stalemate but it's still a draw
because neither neither side can check
made the other side ever so in this
position you just shake your hands and
you go on to the next game all right and
now I'm gonna go to the next position
now here there are actually two pins
that Y can make two pins let's give
everybody else a chance see if somebody
else can figure out the answer fine
try to find pins for white
so the reason why we like to pin is
because it helps us to win pieces and if
we win pieces we get checkmate more
often yes excellent very good Queen to
g1 and that pins what to wide right
Bishop to King so the bishop once you
play Queens you won this bishop cannot
move because otherwise it would be Wyatt
it would be Chuck great so what's the
other pin anybody find the other pin
let's find the other pin yes in the in
the green and yellow
okay why don't you come up closer
there's a there's a seat right there
that's not gonna block any camera stuff
is that okay yeah there's a key right
there Queen to b3 excellent
okay so between these two let's have a
little vote how many people would play
so Queen b3 and now the work also can't
move because then the King would be in
check right so good job how many people
in the class by a show of hands would
play Queen to b3 how many people would
play the other pin Queen to g'wan okay
so most of you are playing Queen b3 why
yeah well that's that could be true in
certain situations like if there was a
pawn here or something
but works g4 here Queen could just take
it right but you're right that that's
what you need to want to look out for if
there's some way to block the pin then
it wouldn't be as effective yes bingo
right very good right the real reason is
that if you play Queen g1 you're gonna
win this bishop if you play Queen b3
you're gonna win the Rock and the rook
is worth how many and the bishops were
okay so it would be better now let's see
what we got here that's game all right
this is from a very famous game one of
the best games played in many many years
and I actually did an advanced lecture
on this on the that you can find on the
st. Louis chess club channel this is a
game between the world champion Anand
and another really strong player so in
this position black to move and win so
right now you're looking at the game
from the very best chess players in the
world let's see if you can solve what
black should have done in this position
yes the back hey I know you I know you
you're an imposter you're you're you're
normally in my intermediate classes so
like let's uh let's hold off and let
some others solve it first all right so
there's a really strong move for black
hey there you can have a seat right up
here if you want or yeah there's one
seat back there and there's one up here
so whatever you want
you look like very indecisive like
you're deciding which piece to move it's
not a test problem don't worry all moves
are equal okay
yeah
very nice perfect and now what's pinned
in this position what's the key pin that
you're taking advantage of why can't
this pawn take the Queen exactly so this
is a really good one because now this
pawn cannot capture the Queen you see
I'm trying to do and it won't let me and
that's because of this bishop which is
just raking down this diagonal right so
what would the only move for white be
here to play what do you what can wait
do ya yes wait can move the King and
then what would happen then we have a
very typical checkmate a checkmate that
we see all the time yes mm-hmm
it's not just checked but it's checkmate
right excellent and check me because you
got the Queen right against the king and
the queen is protected by why the bishop
so this is a very common check may this
Queen right against the king made yes oh
very good
I'm sure your brother doesn't like it as
much but good job and there's actually
one more checkmate in this position
there's another one yes there is one
more way mm-hmm h1 I think you know what
I think you've got the right move but
you're you might want to sit up closer
because there seemed like you have
trouble seeing um you can just slide a
chair on up closer if you'd like
yes Queen h2 is also check me even
though the queen is not directly in
front of the king this is very effective
too because the only escape square is
covered by what right that the escapes
care is covered by the knight and the
queen is also protected by the nine
alright somebody likes Queen h2 better
so good job guys so everybody see that
Queen takes h3 check so that's how the
world champion won one of the very best
games of his career so the fact that you
guys found it - it's pretty awesome
now here's another good but this one's
not checkmate but White has a really
good move here to take advantage of the
pin try to find the good move for white
here he has a good move you could shoot
you can see there's some some
interesting pins yeah
well that's good you that you notice you
notice the key thing in the position
that this bishop is very strong on this
diagonal right so this pawn can this
pawn move is pawn here no it's pinned by
the bishop so look at the whole rest of
the board and see what that means if
this pawn is pinned
what's unprotected mm-hmm uh-huh okay
but what specifically is unprotected
there's a point that just that this
point right here protects I think
somebody see that couple people see it
yes okay so what would you do
no that's what he suggested and that and
then the King can recapture so you got
better is that what you were gonna say
what were you gonna say
very good Queen chapters g6 and you see
that's very similar at a last time can
this pawn take the Queen nope and so the
King instead just has to move and then
we get to capture what yes we're gonna
have to the 90 next movie can capture
that and white is just it's just winning
all the pieces we could also capture the
pawn that's also going to be very strong
yeah good okay you know this one's wait
to move and win this one is just a one
mover so weight to move and weed in one
move try to find it I want to see I'm
going to see at least half the class
with our hands up
try to look at the pieces that are
pinned in the position and that will
help you find the right move okay good
good good good
anyone else anyone new wasn't answering
any questions yet oh it looks like the
UH know that you got the answer to right
there I'm the green started clapping
it's hard for one year olds to solve
mates five months oh okay sorry that's
even harder is that your brother okay
yeah and what do you think what is it we
wear it wet no not be - I can't queen
bee - doesn't really do that much I know
you have it you look so happy I can tell
by how happy are that you have it sit
down sit down
yeah got it okay so try to see what
pieces pinned in this position let's
identify that first what piece is pin
which piece cannot move do you know
right there no no right behind you in
the black shirt with a skeleton okay but
try to figure out which pieces pinned
which beats can't move yes yes this
Knight can't move right because if this
might move what would it be right it
would be check so because that Knight
can't move any square that that Knight
defends is not really defended right
okay quiet down now I'm starting to
regret your Maya sitting you on the run
let's see okay it seems like a lot of
people got it yes in the pink and the
white bow
you mean no you got better than that you
got better okay settle down and I'll
calling you settle down yes 9f2
but Queen to f7 is checkmate look at
that it's a queen right against the king
the king is the queen is defended by
light fish up and why can't this night
take the Queen pen right very good okay
and now what would wait to hear how do
you pin here find a good opinion
sometimes you pain not just a checkmate
but to win pieces so here you can win a
piece with a good pen we try to find a
pin you want to make it so that if your
opponent moves a piece you can capture
in the blue yeah Bishop to d6 well if
you play Bishop to d6 he can take off
yeah the orange work the d1 excellent
and now it's a play if you play worked
if you won and they played Bishop takes
Bishop you're getting the play wide and
that's even better than just winning
five four three
because next move white is gonna play
what like say with black now plays
Bishop back now how do we follow this up
with the quickest win so we did a pin to
win that rook and now what pieces pin
now another pieces pin do can you see
what pieces pin now and the red jacket
yeah what's pin now see what this work
is doing up here what piece is it
pinning what piece can't move
yes very good so this Bishop is pin now
if you have a pin piece what we see is
we keep want to putting pressure on the
pin piece so how can you put
pressure on the pin piece now how can
you put pressure on the pin piece yep
Bishop to d6 exactly that puts pressure
on the pin piece and now next move
you're just going to take this off and
that will be what
checkmate exactly so very good yes very
good now what would you do is black here
now what you're getting easy you see
that's how it works the same the more
you work on one pattern the easier it
gets as you look at different examples
of the same pattern pin and win yes yes
anyone over here the side of the room
yes no no it's black to move sorry black
to move sorry I guess I didn't L tell
you that guys I did tell you okay good
thanks for my pants are rotted out it's
blacks move not whites move blacks move
yep you got better bishop if I take this
bishop the knight will take back and
everything will be relatively cool ZZZ
so Queen - f - and now why can't I take
back with the bishop exactly because the
bishop e5 is pinning this bishop so we
can go to the square and then when the
King moves now what do we do somebody
else what do we do now to take advantage
of but yet another pin now which piece
is pin which piece is pin now which
piece can't move yes
the work can move without any horrible
cost the bishop can can move as well
because now that King has moved away so
the bishop could take the Queen if it
was white smooth oh yeah that's true
this bishop can't really move to too
many squares but there's not really a
way we can take advantage of that now
but I'm talking about actually a
different piece which if it moves this
Queen will fall yes yes this Knight if
this Knight moves this Queen will fall
right so what's your black do in that
case not take the knight because then
the bishop or the Queen could take back
but what is it Knight protecting nope
the knight is protecting this bishop
here right so that means that we can
just play Bishop takes Bishop right and
now it's a knight takes what happens
yeah well you play what what would you
take care yes exactly we take the Queen
because the Queen is worth how many
points okay good the Queen is worth a
lot so that would be a really good
finish and then meanwhile what are we
threatening here well blacks next move
be yeah what will Black's next move be
mm-hmm
do you know okay what do you guys we'll
try to figure it out what do you think
black would do if those blacks move in
this position what
oh well you got to get closer then
you're gonna be able to see it you can
sit on the floor if you want or you can
bring a chair over closer yeah you got
to be able to see it otherwise gray-gray
sure in the back exactly queen 2h2 it's
very similar that meat that we looked at
earlier right yeah because that's it was
white smooth if Queen to h2 here it's
checkmate because this queen is
protected by why exactly you got to
remember this checkmate it's very
typical okay now this takes advantage of
both the last class that we went that we
had on double attack which is also known
as Wyatt what's another word for double
attack four very good so this is going
to take use of fork and pin and that
happens a lot in chess that there's a
combination of themes when you add a
position so what's the move here for
white white to move relax
white to move and win making use of a
pin and the double attack wait to move
yes
you said it's so simple
not everybody's got it yet all right
let's give everybody else another minute
and you too I know you I know YouTube's
got it do you have it in the pink
sweatshirt what you got
no.not queen age three we well we can't
get to eight chicks here right if we
quit it it would be nice to get our
Queen right new Titan right near the
king because that would help us
checkmate right but we've got to move
here that directly wins the material
right and when I say when material it
means that we're going to be gaining
more pieces in our opponent well more
points more valuable pieces or more
pieces more valuable in this case
excellent yes okay yes Knight to d5 okay
why is that a fork what does that attack
what are the two things that that
attacks when we double attack yeah very
good they're working the Queen and why
is it a pin why is it making use of the
pin yes exactly if the pawn captures the
rook we'll capture on e7 and again a
rook is worth and the knight is only
worth so we made how many points yes so
and not only that it's not all about
points because you never win in chess by
having more points in your opponent but
you can also see our work is very strong
we're attacking s7 we're attacking d7 so
this would be easy for a white to win if
you don't make any big mistake
yes we can try playing Ricky ate at some
point now this one's a little harder
black to move how can you make use of a
pin in order to win material or win
pieces black to move black to move okay
you know you got it getting a lot of
pieces you're gonna get a lot of
questions right I'm gonna have to match
you up against these in the the play
period but try to identify which pieces
pin and then attack it that's the idea
if a piece is pinned and you attack it
and it can't move you get to capture the
piece so that's the whole point right so
first figure out which pieces pin and
then attack it so which piece is pinned
yeah the knight on d4 very good it's the
knight on d4 to move
what would fall what no yes the Queen
right this Queen would capture that
Queen and that's the most valuable piece
on the board
so yes the bishop would take the knight
but then what could recapture it the
pawn would recapture it or the Queen and
either way white would not lose material
right so instead of that and the blue
shirt in the back I haven't heard from
you yet yeah
true but then we could also very good
that's all true but then after the Queen
captures back what could white do
capture with the pawn and then the
material is what right so I mean whites
up wake up one pawn but nothing nothing
too scary so black has much better in
this position yeah what do you think oh
if I now you're attacking the pin piece
but what's the problem with that move so
this this Knight can't move or the Queen
will fall but what has black forgotten
about now White has a really good move
that's why when you play chess you got
to look at the whole board right right
this Bishop can capture this Queen so
even though this Knight was pinned what
else was pinned right this pawn was
pinned also so if black wants to win
material in this position he has to
figure out something more clever so
instead of moving this pawn right away
first
hey let's relax I just don't call out so
instead of playing a5 right away black
has to set it up so that white can't
play Bishop takes Queen how do we do
that yes
huh we could move the Queen but then but
then that then we want to be more
forcing than that because if we move the
Queen like say we move the Queen here
now maybe white would just play work
through one and now his queen is
defended right so we want to try to get
it done right away yes in the orange at
this pawn to f6 but then again maybe
something like rook da one so that when
you play e5 we move the knight here and
we're protected anyone else how do we
break this pin yes
no well again if you play well if you
play Bishop e5 f5 I like that idea
because if I play Knight takes a fine
now you do what Queen takes Queen right
very good idea but I don't have to
accept this instead I can maybe go back
here and now
my name is protected and my queen is
protected so how do we stop this pin how
do we with it with attack how do we make
it so that this Bishop is no longer
pinning this pawn how do we interfere
between that yes
got it no a6 was already suggested
similar but a better execution grey sure
in the back yeah
excellent very good and now the bishop
has to go where where does the [ __ ]
have to go if it wants to move out of
attack she wants to move out of attack
where the bishop have to go g3 and then
now what can black do now that the
bishop is no longer on this diagonal now
the pitcher is no longer in this
diagonal we can actually attack the pin
piece right right mm-hmm yes II five and
now we're gonna win some it we're gonna
win this Knight right because if the
knight moves we get to capture the Queen
and so let's do one more here this one's
white to move and this is a really cool
move because there's lots of pins but
first I want you to tell me about all
the different pins in this decision what
is white pin in because there's multiple
pins there who's like who somebody is
like got a key chain in there okay thank
you whoever did whoever did was doing it
stop it all right so it's white to move
what are the pins in this position yes
well no no no but first I'm asking you
what the pins are which pieces can't
move which pieces are pinned there are
two different pins here try to find all
which pieces are pinned down and can't
move yes
try again
know that this point is not pin this
pawn can move it's two pieces you see a
piece that's pinned very good this work
can not move because it surfs work moves
it would be why check right good what
else know the point of these six can't
move but it's not exactly pinned it's
just uh it's just blockaded right it's
blockaded by this bishop exactly the
second one is that bishop but I think it
can't move because again what would it
be very good so what can white you do in
this position what's that so what can
what you do here so how can we take
advantage of both pins it's not that
simple
Wow that's excellent very very good
Bishop e7 and now this Bishop can take
because of because of work takes King
right we're check obviously you can't
take the ting King but it would be check
and if this work would take then what
again it would be checked so now what's
White's next move gonna be yeah
worked work just captures that fade and
we're gonna win the Queen because you're
not gonna be able to take with the rock
that is a lot of air oh sorry okay I get
rid get rid of it all the arrows
magically see they're all gone and now
Rick thinks I hate and things are really
bad I wanted to show one more and then
we're done we'll play some play some
games alright this one I've got weight
to move in winning this one I want one
of the girls in the class cancel it
because I've got a special prize for you
I've got a copy of my book it's called
play like a girl it's with tactics just
by girl players if you don't win it we
have some upstairs but this one wait to
move and win for one of the girls in the
class sorry boys
this is for the girls so wait to move
and win not today but you will get one
soon
we yeah what's up you got girls you had
your hand up first mm-hmm got it get one
chance it's a pin pin and win oh I'll
give you a hint we want to try to win
the Queen in this position because it's
the most powerful piece and white no
longer has a queen right so we want to
try to figure out a way to win the Queen
yes
you wanna play Knight e5 that's a good
idea but you've got a more direct way
because now it's blacks move so black
can do something like move his King out
of danger so when you want to really do
it immediately
yes what's that if we play work c5 what
will black be able to do right captured
with this pawn exactly so otherwise that
would be a good move okay
yes Bishop c4 excellent and now the King
can't move because if the King if the
Queen can't move because if the Queen
moves what is it see it's not letting me
right
they've been the King on a g8 we get
captured and if the Queen captures on c4
the rook just captures the Queen right
very good okay well you win a copy of
the book and good job everyone you all
did really well today
you